哈喽大家好，欢迎来到我的播客节目，起朱莲冰客，我是大维翁。
这期节目是我在美国访学期间做课的最后一场活动，725沙龙的现场录音。
我和纽约曼谈录的主理人欧阳斌老师聊了我对于纽约乃至美国的观感，穿梭在几个国度之间生活的一些感受，以及稍微行而上一些的话题。
比如说作为一个悲观主义者，如何在这个乱纪园里找到生活的毛点。
回听的时候感觉确实是一场漫谈，但作为我在美国这接近一年时间的总结，倒也恰如其分。
欢迎在美国的听友继续关注725沙龙的其他线下活动，以及他们的衍生播客节目纽约漫谈录，真的算得上是纽约华人的一片精神家园了。
那话不多说，祝大家收听愉快。
我记得你刚搬过来的时候，有一天住所换到上东区了。
然后你说有天晚上你看到老鼠在你面前跑，我就觉得特别对不起你，让你到纽约来受苦了。
没有没有，那你能不能跟我们讲讲，现在你对纽约是个什么观感啊？
我对纽约的观感其实在最近三天变得非常好，大家知道天气很影响一个人对城市的观感。
旅游的时候也是，如果你去到一个城市那几天，天气特别好，你就会觉得这个城市很可爱。
我甚至觉得LA的当场都很可爱，直到我被一个黑人额了一笔之后。
所以纽约我觉得它是，就是昨天我们在一个播客节上面在说嘛，它是一个非常复杂混沌的城市。
然后我对它的第一观感其实不是特别的好，因为我是从，如果听我播客的朋友可能知道，我是从日本过来的。
就是你感觉你从世界的一种运行模式，一种极度秩序的运行模式，来到了一个极度没有秩序的运行模式。
那种culture shock，可能比你直接从中国国内来还要更加的明显。
所以刚开始的时候，我有一段时间，我记得我讲过这个故事，就是我进了那个CVS，然后我发现居然有一些柜子是被锁住的。
我觉得我这很久没有，很多年没有在一个，你比如说日本的便利店，或者在中国的什么商店里见到柜子被锁住的。
就那种给你的不安感是一个非常直接具体的一个表现。
然后后来就是刚才欧阳老说的搬到上东，因为有很多朋友跟我讲说，因为我前面两个月住在Jersey City。
所有人都说你来纽约一共就不到一年的时间，你难道不真的体验一下纽约生活吗？
其实我在来之前查那个住址的时候，是不知道Jersey City不属于纽约的。
就是我对美国的无知甚至到了，我都不知道那是另外一个州。
后来一个偶然的机会有一个朋友说，他正好要离开纽约一段时间，说你可以住我那里。
我想这挺好的，就是搬到了上东。
吃一个很老的co-op，所以也趁机体验了一些真正的老New Yorker的。
Literally住在我们那个co-op里边，我觉得平均年龄可能是65。
他们有个笑话，就是当时蒙大尼选举的时候，我们那一小块是整个曼哈顿岛上唯一一个没有投他的选区。
就是后来那个颜色出来，只有那一小块颜色不一样，对对对，是红的。
所以就是那样一个区域，然后你就会感觉到里面的人可能都在里面住了有四五十年，甚至更久的时间。
然后慢慢的我就会觉得纽约这个城市在我面前就变得很多样化，就是认识了很多人，最核心的还是认识了很多人。
这里的人非常非常有趣，不管这个城市有多贵，多混乱，有多么的奇怪，
但至少证明的人是特别的可爱多元，以及我之前生活也已经有七八个城市了吧，就长期，我说超过一年的。
这里的人我觉得是最复杂多样的，所以对于一个城市的观感，它分成几块。
如果说到现在为止，这里的基础设施依然经常让我有一点觉得还是有很多改善的空间的。
我也不知道世界杯对这个城市，日本人的礼貌的表达是吧？
对，因为不是在进行世界杯嘛。
他们说好像纽约市政府还投了挺多钱为了改造这个城市。
没看出来是吧？
我没看出来，就是我经常跑，我今天早上还去应该叫Ease River吧，就是那个河边跑步。
就有一块在我去年第一次在那里跑步的时候，他就在修，他到现在还在那里修，他修了大半年，我不知道他在修什么，
但反正一直跑不过去，然后今天我跑到那个地方的时候发现另外一边也开始修了，
于是我的跑步只剩下了500米的这个距离，
我说这个地方感觉也不太欢迎我继续在这里跑步了。
所以你迫不及待地想回到日本了？
至少短期吧，对，就是。
但是你来这之前，你跟我说过你其实立了一个flag，
你说你要跟100个你的听友，caffe chat，
然后昨天说基本都完成了。
完成了，完成了。
在座的可能有一些，见到一些熟悉的面目，
但是有些朋友特别不好意思，就是他们后来给我打招呼说，
因为100个人真的有点多，就是我会面孔会重叠起来。
但是每一个人他们的一些非常具体的特点我都还记得。
天呐，那我当时听到你完成这个指标的时候，
我第一反应，你得喝多少咖啡啊？
有些朋友是喝酒，有些朋友是吃饭，其实种类很多样。
那你跟这100人这么密集的交流完之后，
你对这个城市有什么观感上的变化吗？
因为这个就不太一样了，跟你的体感可能就是发生一个不一样的伪度的。
对，因为其实我刚才说这个城市变得可爱起来，也是因为这里的人嘛。
其实一大部分是因为我聊的这些听友，
当然他们不光是在纽约，就是我因为这9个月我充分利用他，
我大概走了有十几个周去了很多城市，
当然有些时间短，有些时间长一些，
几乎每个城市我都有聊一些朋友。
但纽约的我感觉，当然偏科技金融类的朋友会更多一些。
但是真正那些做特别不一样事情的听友都是在纽约。
你有什么做什么让你特别没想到的事的人吗？
其实聊的第一个听友，我不知道他今天来没来啊，是一个做艺术投资的。
就他听起来跟金融有点关系，但他又是艺术圈的。
他是议考上来，然后帮中国的很多大佬去管他们的艺术藏品。
所以他在这一年带了我去了好些很有趣的纽约，
大家知道那个画廊，就是最好的画廊，其实都在这里有他的地方。
都是当代语，是我最不懂的那种艺术类别看不懂。
但是他就说，那如果你要做艺术投资这个类别，你就只能在纽约。
几乎在全世界范围内，只有纽约这里是最权的，
可以去去参加各种展啊，然后去做一些买卖的动作。
然后还有很多，比如说在这里有很多学校里的人，
就是教育系统的，在教育系统里面做老师的，
甚至是做一些人力资源等等这些领域的朋友。
其实他们看到的纽约就和我觉得跟科技金融类的这些庭友很不一样。
比如说他们更多的关注到的是下一代现在的一个情况，
来美国的留学生，甚至有一个朋友就是负责给留学生他的签证，
就是能不能让他来，最近一两年就真的有一些，不是说中国的，
而是一些甚至是比较小国的国家的学生，就是申请都过了，
但是最终这个签证下不来的结果来不了。
所以他跟我讲了很多这方面的故事，我觉得还是挺有意思的。
感觉你到这儿来这个上山下乡体验生活了。
因为我觉得我其实在日本住了两年多，我没有见，
几乎没有见任何的庭友或者怎么样。
除非他们专程跑来连仓说我们来喝咖啡，
那我当然一定会要接待。
比如说我。
对对对，包括欧阳老师。
专门去了连仓。
可能有那么两三个，
但是我当然觉得我来美国既然时间这么短，
然后我一定要充分的利用好他，
那我自己人肉也能看到的还是很有限的。
通过这些庭友，其实他们就是一双一双眼睛。
跟庭友聊特别棒的一点是，坐下来我不用自我介绍。
我也不用说任何我的故事，
他们很多人对我的很多故事特别的了解。
所以他们非常能敞开心扉的，
就跟我聊他们想聊的事情，
或者他们在做的事。
甚至有很多朋友过来直接跟我讲说，
我能给你提供一个很不一样的data point。
我的经历肯定跟你聊过的很多朋友不一样。
我印象特别深有一个，
其实已经应该有五十多的一个朋友，
他应该是在这边的一个党派的办公室里，
就是议员参议员的办公室里做事情。
然后他就说你之前聊的那天我肯定都年轻，
然后都在这边上学什么的。
我告诉你，
就是现在美国特别是纽约这边，
真实的一些这种政治的情况，
或者怎么样。
我觉得他给了一个我非常，
到现在印象特别深刻，
我可能后面会用回国，
因为我一定会被很多人问，
美国怎么样啊，纽约怎么样啊。
他给了我一个比喻，
他说纽约是一个是一盘沙拉，
说看起来都在一起对吧，
一盘有番茄，有黄瓜，有这个包菜什么。
但是其实条理分明，
这次是分的很开的。
这里说的可以是族群，
可以是不同的阶层都可以。
所以你吃起来，
你会感觉他可能是一盘菜，
但是如果你细分看来，
每一个都有非常不一样的，
自己的一个群体，
一个社群，
或者生活。
我觉得这个比喻还挺，
因为我原来一直在想用一个什么比喻来形容，
纽约,
他显然不是一个我们原来以为的一个大荣辱，
就是什么大家都顿在一锅里，
对，顿在一锅里，
就好像都生活的在一起，
其实不是这样的，
我来之后最大的感觉就是不是这样的。
那到底用什么来形容呢？
我觉得沙拉这个词，
还挺妙的。
哎，那我想知道就是，
他刚才提到的，
做画廊的，
大学的老师，
还有这个，
发明这个，
纽约是沙拉比喻的，
听有今天有在，
在现场吗？
没有说，
或者不好意思。
都不在，
希望你说的是真的。
最好是真的。
不光说纽约，
其实我觉得这也是，
后面我特别感兴趣一个话题，
就是说你其实在中国也住了好久，
然后在日本，
这一晃也都有好几年了，
两年多，
三年,
小三年的样子，
然后在美国这一次，
也算是，
九月,
这三个地方，
你怎么评价呢？
你有什么经典的比喻吗？
除了沙拉以外，
比喻,
或者你想想，
他给你的，
观感是什么？
因为太有意思了，
这三个国家。
对对对，
这三个国家，
就是非常非常的不同，
但是因为，
我觉得是直到，
我来到日本生活的时候，
我才跳脱出，
一个完全牛马的身份，
去观察这个社会，
然后当时正好，
因为也是刚疫情结束嘛，
就是你已经被憋在一个地方，
憋了太久了，
所以你到了一个新的地方，
你会觉得一切都那么的新鲜，
就是,
他完全跟你原来的整个生活的状态，
然后人，
他们的一些表达，
完全的不同，
所以你每天都感觉在看新的东西，
然后等到好不容易，
稍微有一点习惯熟悉了之后，
突然又跳到了一个，
美国我原来也从来没有来过，
就是一个完全不一样的地方，
然后发现这里的，
所有人的状态，
又跟日本，
特别的不同，
如果你一定要让我说的话，
我觉得，
日本是一个活在，
很过去的社会，
就大家如果去过日本玩的话，
一定会非常的舒适，
舒适的原因在于，
他没有那么多吵闹的，
现在的新的一些东西，
他提供的服务，
依然是，
可能跟二十年前，
三十年前，
当然你站在当地人，
他会觉得不如了，
他觉得也开始下降了，
但是,
相比其他国家的变化来说，
他的变化非常的缓慢，
还保留了我们家旁边，
我当时在联赛的家旁边，
甚至还有一个送报纸的站，
每天早上，
还有人去那里，
把报纸拿来，
然后C到各家，
好像美国都没有了吧，
美国还有吗？
很有吧，
我觉得我还看到过，
那种丢报纸，
装的塑料袋，
OK,
就是,
日本也是还有很多，
中国肯定已经没有，
中国是真的应该没有了，
中国连报刊亭都没有了，
日本的杂志的销量，
报纸的销量，
依然是，
他们获取信息的一个很重要的来源，
所以你会觉得日本是一个活在过去的国家，
中国,
感觉介于，
我觉得美国是生活在现在的国家，
因为它有一部分在过去，
有一部分在未来，
然后因为我去加州，
然后在这边，
我因为来美国，
完全就是观察嘛，
就是我每天都在试图观察，
AI趋势到底有到哪里了，
然后现在的这个所谓的affordability的，
在喊着这些人的那一个社群，
他们在发生什么，
你就会发现，
它代表的就是现在整个，
它就像国际的一个，
缩引,
就是割裂啊，
或者说K型分化啊，
等等这些词，
就是在us presence,。
正在发生的事情，
然后中国，
中国大家，
如果出去玩儿，
有的时候会觉得，
就未来感还挺强的，
你不管说是这些，
互联网的服务，
外卖啊，
滴滴啊，
这些东西之外的话，
你包括去看，
所有最新的东西，
都一定会在很多的城市，
被立刻应用上去，
因为我在离开中国之前，
我在一个机器人企业，
工作了两年，
我们当时要去跟各个地方政府，
去谈融资，
然后去谈落地工厂，
你就会发现，
哪怕是到一个，
中部的审分的，
二三线的城市，
它的主政官，
我们只是一个估值，
大概二十亿人民币，
也就是大概两三亿美元，
其实是一个很小很小的，
小小独角兽，
然后,
他们的市长，
都会愿意来，
亲自跟我们谈，
就是你们的机器人的这个东西，
怎么可以落在我们这儿，
可以用在我们什么地方，
他们真的是，
中国的每个城市，
都想要体现出，
未来的一些景象，
只不过有些成功了，
有些,
没有那么成功，
招揽不来，
这类企业而已，
在日本美国，
都看不到这样的景，
日本我们，
因为,
在日本又有业务嘛，
我后来其实，
先到日本，
是在那个公司的，
相当于日本分社，
做负责人，
所以,
我跟日本的人打交道，
就会发现，
他们的，
主政官就不说了，
他们的企业，
想要应用，
这些机器人技术，
都停留在PPT上面，
就是,
日本人做事情，
他要,
光PPT,
可能要改个三五版吧，
所有事情，
先做PPT,
然后再，
进入到一轮一轮的，
他们就搜登，
就是商谈中，
然后在最后再落地，
所以,
特别特别的慢，
然后他们的，
这些政府，
也会说，
我们要面对未来，
物流机器人的，
所以,
什么物流DX，
之类的，
这种东西，
然后你去一看，
他们给的时间表，
都是五年后要怎么样，
十年后要怎么样，
那,
中国都是按照，
下个月我要怎么样，
明年我们要怎么样，
所以,
那你对于企业来说，
我到底，
想要在什么地方，
去落地，
就一目了然了，
在美国，
就更奇怪了，
就是,
如果你说AI的话，
他们都告诉你，
下个礼拜又不一样了，
但是你说地铁的话，
就是十年以后，
还是这样的，
没错没错，
而且你跟不同的，
在美国这块，
你跟不同的人，
说他的反应，
是完全不同的，
那在中国，
可能大家都会偏兴奋，
哪怕现在，
基层牛马，
可能被AI折磨得很厉害，
但是依然大家，
想要去吸收这个东西，
但日本，
就是绝大部分人，
是抗拒的，
就是我不愿意，
去跟你聊，
聊这个事情，
说完这三个国家，
之后,
就说到我们自己，
比如像你这样的，
一个,
所谓的，
华侨了吧，
现在也算是，
混成华侨了，
现在也觉得特别搞笑，
那你看，
现在中美关系，
不好,
中日关系，
也不好，
请问大老师，
你觉得，
生活在美国，
日本的华侨们，
未来,
还有希望吗？
什么,
你说的，
希望是值，
你自己理解，
就是,
还有什么，
可搞的地方吗？
我觉得，
中日关系，
跟中美关系，
还是很不一样的，
就是,
虽然我不是，
国际关系的专家，
就是,
你会发现，
中日冷下来，
不就冷下来了吗？
然后后来，
急剧的恶化之后，
他们两个国家，
不是他们，
我们,
这两个国家之间的，
脱钩,
可以脱得很明显，
就是,
他们在经济上的，
相互的，
依存程度，
本身就没有那么的高，
甚至你可以说，
日本,
我在日本看到，
Made in China的这个东西，
比例,
远远没有，
我在美国看到，
Made in China的高,。
就他们是以，
日本制造，
或者说是，
因为日本在东南亚，
有很多的，
资本的这个运作，
这个为主的，
所以我感觉，
日本一说到，
中国对他们的制裁，
可能就是一些稀土，
有一些，
但稀土也不是第一轮了，
他们十年前，
就已经被中国搞过一轮，
所以,
我会感觉，
很难看到，
就是下面，
他们要怎么再重新，
热落起来，
除非日本这边，
政府换借，
或者是这样的，
但中美，
你的感觉就是，
两个国家，
至少在现在，
脱钩不了，
就是不管是人员的流动，
然后,
资本的流动，
包括这个，
商品啊，
等等的流动，
都太频繁了，
我记得，
我第一篇公众号文章，
就是关于，
一八年，
川普在国会上面的一个发言，
当时他要提出，
跟中国打贸易战，
当时中国是非常的，
措手不及的嘛，
但是他的那个，
国会的整个发言，
就非常直接了当地，
在说这件事情，
你会发现，
打了这么久之后，
今年反而是，
他要回到中国，
去跟,
跟,
我们的国家主席，
去见面，
然后去谈，
这个商业的事情，
但是,
你很难想象，
日本的，
日本从来，
最近二十年都没有，
说是首相，
带着一帮，
这个社长们，
跑去中国去，
做这个事情，
甚至因为前两年，
因为日本的很多企业的这个，
小孩,
在中国发生了一些，
意外的事件，
导致,
日本的商业上，
是大幅的，
把这些人撤回来，
以及也没有人愿意去了，
所以我感觉，
对于这两个国家里，
生活的华人来说，
面对的情形也完全不同，
日本的华人，
可能会，
更加的严峻一些，
曾经有过一段时间，
就在两个国家，
过去几年，
还比较热落的时候，
其实,
感觉在日华人，
是迎来了一波，
重新的机会，
就是有很多的中国的，
我记得当时，
最多的这种，
方式是，
我到日本去看，
因为日本的这些，
一些,
养老业啊，
然后医护业啊，
等等的是，
中国明显，
马上要面对的情况，
所以有很多的，
考察团过来，
然后呢，
中国的很多的企业的，
二代想到，
日本来收一个，
老的品牌，
或者是，
因为日本就是断代了，
就日本有一些，
老的手工艺品啊，
等等的，
它就断掉了，
所以,
那段时间，
曾经是非常热落的，
但是一下子，
就冷下来了，
就这个事情，
在日的华人，
也没有那么多生意，
可以去做，
至少在这方面，
但是美国这边，
我感觉，
华人可以做的事情，
就还很多，
哪怕只是，
在中美之间的，
这个贸易往来的事情，
就还可以做非常多，
它一定会反映在，
经济的冷热，
你只要去看，
进出口的这个，
数据啊，
然后包括，
嗯,
这些国家的，
这些高层，
就是企业的高管，
愿不愿意去，
彼此的国家，
你来判断，
这两个国家的商业，
往来,
你就可以看到，
中日跟中美，
根本就，
不在一个阶层上的，
所谓的关系，
恶化。
不可否认的，
就是说，
我们曾经熟悉的，
那个全球化时代，
已经结束了，
那现在，
越来越多的，
都是大家把强力起来，
比如说，
你申请一个签证，
现在,
其实难度是，
越来越高，
无论是工作签，
学生签，
旅游签，
从舆论上面来说，
更是,
这种,
比较敌对的声音，
是越来越大了，
那我想知道，
比如说，
像你自己，
也是四海为家，
现在,
到处转游，
那你个人，
你一个肉身来，
在这个雨晶下面，
就是一个，
发生了极大转变的，
这么一个雨晶下面，
在全球转游来，
转游去，
你的感觉，
你觉得全球化，
是个未命题了吗？
或者说，
是一个，
已经慢慢示威了，
一个趋势了吗？
看你再说的是，
什么层面，
你如果说的是，
这个供应链，
它一定是，
已经变成一个过去史了，
就是所谓的，
以前,
我一定要把，
工厂放在中国，
然后把，
什么,
上游资源品，
放在南美，
或者放在东南亚，
然后,
销售放在欧美，
就这个时代，
肯定是已经结束了，
原因,
有很多，
地缘政治的原因，
经济的原因，
等等的原因，
但是,
如果你说，
文化上的，
我们就单说，
文化这一层，
你会发现，
因为现在的，
你在说，
算法也好，
社交媒体也好，
整个,
AI的这个浪潮也好，
它反而会变得更快了，
就是,
比如说韩潮，
所谓的韩潮，
韩国的这个文化，
它的流行程度，
就是属于，
在全世界范围内，对吧，
现在说起拉布布，
好像有一点，
这个,
遥远了，
但是它也是，
就是一夜间，
可能在全球，
就会活起来，
就这个，
你说它是全球化，
退潮之后的，
产物,
怎么理解这件事情呢？
其实,
是不一样的，
而且我在美国，
会发现，
哇,
美国的年轻人，
这么喜欢日本动画，
是我没有想到的，
我去,
电影院，
看那个，
电剧人的剧场版，
我就发现，
做的全是黑人，
这个,
年轻人，
爆蜜花在里面，
看,
然后看，
特别激动，
这种情形，
你说,
全球化已经结束了，
它显然，
只是在某一些方面，
有一些冷却，
但是反而，
因为信息的，
整个传递，
更加的快乐之后，
至少我觉得，
Z时代,
对于,
Gen Z,
来说,
他们已经没有，
他们在文化上，
没有太多，
国家的这个概念，
它只有我喜欢这个，
和我不喜欢，
这个的这个概念，
它可能是，
另外一个国家的，
对,
不太一样，
就是我每次，
跟国内的朋友，
我就只说中国人，
跟他们聊的时候，
我感觉，
明显感觉，
疫情之后这几年，
大家对，
出国来看看，
的兴趣，
越来越低，
对,
这个我感觉，
它跟,
全球化这些东西，
关系不大，
它其实是，
一个经济体，
进入到一个阶段之后，
会发生的事情，
原因是，
因为在日本，
也是一样的，
我印象特别深，
我在联葬的健身教练，
它是一个，
四十多岁的，
中年人，
去打工，
打工的那个钱，
就购它来美国，
玩一趟，
日本人，
那是八十年代末吧，
八十年代，
反正是，
对,
汇率也值钱，
然后对，
经济也比较好，
它的属膝工，
就是去Toyota，
去封田，
对,
去宁罗斯吧，
可能是，
我不知道，
但是你会发现，
到了现在，
到了令和之后，
日本的年轻人，
已经完全不愿意，
出国了，
你在纽约，
可能日本人，
大家见到的，
日本阿姨，
她在这边，
已经住了四十年了，
就很少见到，
日本人的生意，
我们上次去日本，
开会的时候，
其实他们也提到，
甚至会有大学的，
博士神，
提议,
他的教授说，
你不要叫，
什么国际关系研究院，
对不对，
改名叫，
国内关系研究院，
就够了，
就是,
我不需要了解这个世界，
那你发现，
中国其实，
某种程度上，
它在走一个，
同样的路，
它走这个路的原因，
是在于，
当你在物质上，
已经完全，
成了海外，
甚至,
基础说，
是比海外更好之后，
那我出来看看，
我到底是，
看什么，
就这个，
目标变得，
不像像，
原来那么的，
明确了，
所以大家出来，
就一定会有，
更多的考量，
比如说，
我就是，
专门要看，
这个自然风光，
或者是，
我就是，
专门想去，
我之前一直看的电影，
或者是，
文化的一个，
朝圣的之旅，
它不会像以前，
我们就觉得，
海外,
看不到，
所以我要出来看看，
所以我，
我个人倒不觉得，
这个是，
全球化退潮的，
一个表现，
是呢,
这个就说你自己吧，
就是,
其实当时，
我也有点惊讶，
比如说，
在联场，
我要请你，
到美国来，
你就,
非常高兴的接受了，
我当然还挺surprise，
在日本，
这么,
上好水好，
文明,
有秩序，
干净的一个地方，
它竟然这么愿意，
到纽约来吃苦，
是,
当时也不知道，
那你自己，
为什么这么愿意，
到处溜的呢？
哎,
我觉得，
我们这一代，
或者说是，
GNC之前的，
中国人，
都会有一种，
我要去看世界，
就是,
我想要拥抱这个世界，
我想,
世界人是一个，
很好的词，
嗯,
就是,
所以你从小，
你就会觉得，
如果我能出来看，
多看看的话，
是一件，
非常好的事，
这个,
哪怕在我，
已经走过这么多，
国家之后，
依然,
都在,
它跟,
后面的时代的人，
它是需要一个，
很长时间的，
这个世代的，
遷移,
它这种理念，
才会改变，
你讲日本，
也是到了，
二零零零，
然后二零一零，
再往后走，
到现在这个时代，
OK,
终于大家消磨了，
那个,
想要来海外的，
这个观念了，
但是对于我，
以及我身边的朋友，
嗯,
以及比我在小一点的朋友，
其实也都是一样的，
就是会觉得，
如果我有机会，
多看看这个世界，
或者去哪里，
就是深度体验吧，
就不是这种，
只是去玩两天，
是一件非常好的事情，
我也不知道说，
好在哪儿，
就是它到底能给我带来什么，
可能在那个当下，
是不明确的，
就一种价值观吧，
就觉得这事是对的，
对,
底层的就觉得，
我应该拥抱世界，
对吧,
对,
我觉得最底层的事情，
还是因为我们，
不是互联网员著名，
就是在我们的小时候，
这个世界是，
非常非常，
要用眼睛跟脚去照亮的，
嗯,
你不能说，
我看过一个虚拟的，
这个世界，
我看过了，
但我觉得，
对于现在，
再往年轻一代的人走，
它会,
它这个现实跟虚拟，
就非常的融合了，
它会觉得，
我在上面看过了，
就是看过了，
可以了，
我没有必要，
再到这个，
当场去看，
这可能也是一种，
一种想法，
就我跟一些零零后的朋友，
他们给了我一些，
让我受到冲击的词，
比如说，
你知道什么叫，
中式梦合吗？
他们都不是零零后，
没有,
有,
我不知道，
对对对，
中式梦合，
它形容呢，
就是一种，
其实我们以前都经历过的一些，
中国老旧的那个时代，
可能是一个舞斗柜，
上面有一个，
闪着雪花点的电视，
然后有一个，
非常昏黄的一个状态，
就是它，
它形容的是一种状态，
然后,
对于现在的很多，
很多 GenZ 来说，
它对于中国过去的，
想象,
它就是通过这样子的一个，
形态,
然后说，
你醒了，
就是2000年，
但我很想提醒那些年轻人，
其实2000年不是这个样子的，
可能要再往前走过10年，
15年才是那个，
他们想象中的梦合的样子，
但我就想说的就是，
你会发现，
每一代的人，
他对于这个世界，
他想要去观察的方式，
就变了，
就不一样了，
以及我们应该理解这种变化，
正好也有很多你的听友在，
这个可能，
你也聊过，
但是我觉得，
我当然，
跟你聊过挺多这个话题，
但是我也，
想今天，
在这儿，
我们再讲一讲，
就说,
那说到你自己的话，
那你当时，
为什么，
一个金融精灵不做了，
要慢慢离开呢，
这么好的一个职业呢？
其实,
这不是一个，
突然的，
就是说，
我突然想通了一件事情，
或者说，
现在很多朋友说，
我fire了,
我好像，
攒钱攒到了一个点，
我就可以做出这样的决定的，
我现在如果回想起，
当时离开金融行业的那，
半年一年，
它是一个反复拉扯的关系，
就是,
我曾经，
本来就差点要，
入职另外一家公务基金，
它的创始人其实，
刚刚去世，
我跟它，
就是在疫情期间，
我们两视频聊了，
大概有五六个小时，
就聊得非常好，
我觉得，
他们这公司也非常有趣，
但最后就是，
一些机缘巧合的原因，
我就没去，
我就说，
我当时，
之前一直有一个想法说，
我想到日本去，
好好地学一下日语，
我们是从小被，
日本文化图读的一代，
老二四年，
对，可以在电视上，
看到日本动漫的一代，
那我觉得，
反正现在，
我暂时没有什么事情了，
所以我，
那我就可以去，
做这件事了，
然后它就，
我就做了，
做了之后，
慢慢地我会发现，
其实我好像也没有那么，
需要再回到一个，
金融机构里面，
去做一份，
职场人的工作，
它不是一个，
突然的一个决定，
就是你突然发现你的钱够了，
那就是没有突然，
但是确实有那一个瞬间，
就是你要算一下说，
OK,
如果你不要瓦，
然后你，
这个,
也没有想要在网上，
加一个零的话，
也许我现在的，
整个资产的，
积累已经足够我，
对,
先休息，
一段,
或者甚至休息很长时间，
但我还是，
我一直，
为什么不想分享，
什么,
所谓的，
File的秘诀啊，
或者什么，
我觉得我们这，
这一个时代，
都是享受了，
充分享受了，
中国的房地产，
时代红利的一代，
虽然我没有因此，
真的赚到，
很多很多钱，
但至少你会因此，
一时无忧，
那是在，
你在懵懵懂懂的时候，
就是你在工作了一两年之后，
你觉得，
哦,
我好像租一个房，
跟我买一个房，
然后,
附带款是差不多的钱，
那我就买了，
然后过了几年，
就涨这么高，
那我就卖了，
然后又换房了，
就是它，
它是在一个，
你是在那个，
对,
你是裹挟着，
完成了，
一个资本的原始积累的，
所以这个东西，
没有什么，
没有任何的绝窍可以，
分享,
存在这样的一个，
一个可能性，
对,
一会儿我们可以聊，
就是这个时代的红利，
有的时候真的就是，
可欲不可求，
对,
但不同的人会遇到，
或者不同的时代，
它会遇到不同的红利，
对,
转回来还是说你自己，
比如说你从金融领域，
变成一个，
自媒体人，
一个主理人，
这个,
怎么突然发现，
只有这个技能技巧呢，
可以干这个事，
其实它也是慢慢的，
就是,
我在离开主权基金之后，
去的一个公司，
然后它需要，
它需要做一些，
连接金融知识，
和普通人的，
哎，说得直白一点，
就是现在大家可能知道，
有一批那个，
中资券商不是被，
封了嘛，
在国内不允许，
国内人投资了，
当时在，
那是大概多少年，
九年前，
我们那个公司，
就曾经想做过这个事情，
那做这个事情，
你首先要告诉中国的这些人，
海外市场到底是什么嘛，
对吧,
然后这些金融市场，
到底要怎么投资，
然后那个时候，
我被招进去，
是以研究员的身份招进去，
但没想到做的事情，
是管一个公众号，
但我也没有觉得，
这事儿有什么，
特别大的问题啊，
因为当时，
还觉得挺新鲜的，
就是,
做自媒体，
当时是公众号，
后来做播客，
其实你一个很大的，
驱动力在于，
它是即时反馈的一个东西，
就是你每天都能看到，
你的阅读量，
然后你的一些评论，
什么的，
它在不断的变化，
然后你就能立刻，
它跟上班的时候，
你得到的这个反馈是，
从时间上，
跟质量上都是不一样的，
对，你的上班时候，
你要得到反馈，
必须得是你老板给你的，
或者到年底，
通过bonus来体现的，
但是在做自媒体的这个时候，
你如果做得好，
你就是立刻就有一个体现，
做的哪怕OK，
也有人马上就递死你，
对，当然你反向的，
这个负面的反馈，
也是非常快的，
但那个时候就会觉得，
这个事儿好像可以做，
是因为，
在这个时代，
就是有很多的媒体人，
做财经内容，
但是很少有金融人，
愿意去做媒体内容，
就下行了嘛，
你阶级下流了嘛你，
对吧，不能这么说，
金融也不是什么上流，
但金融人比，
跟媒体人比，
因为做金融人，
欧阳老师可以这么说，
因为他是老媒体人，
我一直在下游，
转游的那种，
因为金融，
大家的那个合规意识，
太强了，
就是你如果，
还在那个机构里面，
有很多话，
你能说不能说的，
就是你会控制，
你会考虑很多，
对,
所以我一直在说，
这个世界上，
跟我有同样履厉的人，
可能少有个10万人吧，
但这10万人里面，
首先能够表达的人，
可能是1%，
然后愿意表达的人，
又是这1%中的1%，
那你成下来，
就只剩10个人了，
就剩你了，
就没多少人，
会做这个事了，
所以当然就觉得，
这事儿，
其实就算不做为一个工作，
我在咸瞎时间来做，
也还挺有趣的，
所以后来就一直在做，
我的公众号，
然后公众号做到一个时间点，
这一波其实，
整个机制改了之后，
现在我不知道大家现在，
还会不会看公众号，
我觉得现在公众号的整个改到，
你已经不知道，
你要怎么触达到你的读者了，
我在2022年的时候，
开始做播客，
然后你会发现，
我现在想，
为什么我做播客，
不做短视频，
或者是什么，
是因为，
本身我想表达的东西，
就不是那种，
用三句话，
或者是用一两分钟的东西，
能表达清楚的，
三分钟教你致富，
就是,
它是那种，
让你提早退休那种，
对，或者说，
你碰到一个事件，
我用三分钟告诉你，
为什么你现在，
就必须得买，
就类似这样的一些表达，
是这个时代，
最主流的，
一些信息流，
跟短视频的表达，
那如果你不喜欢这个东西的话，
你能用什么媒介，
去做表达呢？
那,
音频,
其实是现在很多人，
回归到的一个，
因为就大家去听播客，
你其实是不希望，
三分钟这个播客就结束了，
你觉得我又要立刻要换节目，
好麻烦呀，
然后甚至有很多朋友告诉我，
他们也不喜欢那种，
播客前面剪高光，
就是什么，
我把几句金句，
放到最前面，
他会觉得，
我就是要替你的全部的逻辑，
你告诉我那几句，
莫名其妙的话在那里，
没有意义，
你就会发现，
他完全是跟，
短视频的逻辑是反的，
然后有些人，
可能更适合去做，
这种短视频类的自媒体，
那我觉得，
偏这种，
如果你想讲的话，
不是特别的，
独定的话，
你想讲一个完整的逻辑的话，
那可能就是要用一种，
比较慢的，
用播客这种方式，
去跟大家去聊，
本质上，
你还是有很多话想说，
对吧,
你还是很喜欢，
表达的一个，
我觉得表达预，
是做内容创作者的前提吧，
就是,
如果你想表达这件事情，
都是一个负担，
或者说是，
因为我看到，
很多做播客的朋友，
在一开始就说，
哎呀，我怎么样，
可以快速起亮，
或者说，
我可以立刻有流量，
然后,
很多老播客人，
给他们的建议说，
你先做个三十七，
五十七再说，
你不就这么跟我说的吗？
对，我就是这么跟你说的，
这个其实是，
刘飞跟我说的，
首先你是得有表达预的，
你如果非要耗三十个嘉宾，
来给你聊是很难的，
你得自己得吧得能说一些，
所以这个，
我觉得是做内容创作者，
如果你不是把它做一个商业，
你不是把它做一个生意，
而是你真的想，
做内容的人的一个前提。
但是,
这一点上，
又有一点，
我觉得特别好奇，
像你作为，
金融训练背景的人，
应该,
表达上面非常的克制，
且经常会带一句，
就是,
本建议不构成投资，
什么什么，
但是,
就仔细听你节目，
其实我认真听过很多很多，
到现在也是，
上次我给你看过，
就是,
在我那个收听榜里面，
排第二的，
谢谢谢谢，
第一是谁来着？
那个,
哎呀,
陈彥良叫什么来着？
胡索胡诱，
对,
哎,
这不是我的隐私吗？
对,
我当时给他看过，
因为当时那个胡索胡诱，
杨一不是咱们一起录节目吗？
对对对，
我给你们俩看了，
就是说，
为什么把你们俩喊过来？
但是,
仔细听你的节目，
对吧,
这也发生过，
就是你给我讲过，
就是,
如果有听有跟你，
三观不合，
上来,
光光光，
一顿输出，
在评论区，
你一般什么态度呢？
我觉得我以前的态度，
跟现在的态度，
差别还挺大的，
现在我可能，
直接就删了，
你不是告诉过我，
永远不要删评论吗？
是是是，
开玩笑开玩笑，
我觉得，
取决于他的表达，
是有逻辑的，
还是只是一个观点的，
我就说，
就是毫无逻辑，
只喷情绪的那种，
只喷情绪，
那我觉得，
真的是没有什么必要留，
因为,
很简单，
我这个是跟那个，
众数,
跟独株不成林的主播，
在聊的时候，
我们得达到的一个共识，
就是,
那个账号，
就是这个评论区的那个人，
可能就是一个账号，
对吧,
他其实对你的这个主播，
他是听了你整个表达之后，
他的一个反应，
但对于我们来说，
我只能看到，
这个账号，
他说的这句话，
我根本不知道他的前因后果，
我也不知道他，
为什么会有这个情绪，
就这个东西，
没有办法，
通过这一句话，
表达出来，
他以为，
他在上面留个言，
可能,
主播就能知道，
他在想什么，
其实是不知道的，
所以,
这个是一个非常大的，
不对等，
就是你不能，
指望我能共情你，
就是你通过一句话，
我就能共情你的东西，
但,
如果你，
表达了很多，
甚至不用表达很多，
有一些账号，
比如说，
一直在我评论区出现，
他会让我熟悉了，
我就知道，
他的表达方式是，
什么样子了，
那可能，
我可以，
什么,
但如果，
我对你完全，
一无所知的话，
那天跟谁聊天，
来着,
跟一个朋友聊天，
他就说，
他爸的一些，
说的话，
然后他有一次，
在他的评论区，
看到了一个留言，
结果,
进去发现是他爸，
只看到这个留言，
他会觉得，
这句话简直，
就是莫名其妙，
这个人简直是神经病，
但是,
当他看到那个账号，
是他爸的那一刻，
他完全理解了，
为什么这个人，
要说这句话，
因为你就知道了，
整个,
对吧,
第一,
如果他是，
纯情绪输出，
我的,
大概是不管他，
就是把他掠过去，
但如果他，
涉及到人身攻击，
特别是，
对我的嘉宾，
有人身攻击，
那我肯定是，
删掉他的，
那对你自己呢？
对我自己，
人身攻击，
我删掉，
我干嘛，
留着他，
那你教我的那些招，
你现在都改了，
对对对，
当时你还，
跟我说那个，
我跟你抱怨过，
我那个，
底下有人说，
你看他采访的时候，
还拿个提缸，
然后你跟我说，
哎呀，别在意他们，
结果过两天，
你就跟我抱怨说，
一个听你节目，
很多年的老听友，
突然,
对对对，
我想起来，
就是因为现在，
有一些平台，
他也非常过分，
他有各种标签，
就是可能大家看不到，
但是如果你是那个，
创作者，
你能看到，
这个人关注了你多久，
然后他是什么时候，
关注你的账号，
然后你就，
很生气，
就是你都关注五六年了，
那应该是公众号，
然后为什么，
就是,
会说出这样的一个评论，
但是反过来，
我刚刚说的就是，
你会,
有些人，
他可能在某一件事情上面，
他跟你价值观是，
相同的，
然后,
大家有一个，
共同的基础，
或者他只是想，
从我这得到一些，
财富密码，
也有可能，
所以关注了我，
那他在别的事情上面，
跟我是完全，
对着来的，
就这个事，
也很正常，
其实这个，
我特别好奇，
就是说，
因为你的号也挺大的，
也有这么多听友，
而且我发现，
你跟听友们互动，
还挺花力气的，
就是,
哇,
还回复，
太闲了，
我曾经试图这么去做，
后来发现，
真的是，
没那么多空，
就点个赞，
都不错了，
我想知道，
从另一个角度来说，
就你,
这么大频率，
高频率的，
大,
体量的，
数量级的，
去跟听友的反馈，
给到你，
你都是能看到的，
你从他们的反馈当中，
你能看到一个，
什么样的中国呢？
这个最后，
落脚点这么大吗？
从我的听友的反馈，
看到一个，
什么样的中国？
你肯定看到了，
对,
对我来说，
能看到的最好的东西，
就是,
因为,
很多的，
现在听波克的朋友，
还是比较年轻的，
你看,
在做的，
就能看出来这个，
年龄群，
其实跟你原来的，
七二五沙龙，
可能,
对吧,
不是一个年龄群的，
现在也差不多这样了，
对，你说，
所以,
他们帮助我，
看到了，
更年轻的中国，
一定,
如果一定要用，
这么大的一个，
话语的话，
因为,
你想想看，
报志愿的，
我听了那期，
那一期，
居然评论区，
出现了很多高中生，
真的,
对,
然后我就说，
你们为什么要听，
这么斑味的波克，
对啊,
怎么找到的，
真的是，
是,
但是你就会觉得，
因为我，
我现在，
越来越多的，
就是一个观察者嘛，
其实,
包括来美国，
在日本，
包括我做波克，
为什么我花这么多时间，
去看评论，
一个是因为，
我做内容，
几乎唯一的目的，
就是获得情绪价值，
因为我也不靠他赚钱，
那,
如何能够获得，
越来越多的情绪价值呢？
就是,
你要鼓励那些，
给你情绪价值的，
评论,
以及一些，
内容,
你这个老狐狸，
就是,
所以你去，
使劲给人家点赞，
回复,
他不一定是，
完全正面，
单纯的夸赞，
他如果是，
在很认真的跟我分享，
他的一件事情，
或者怎么样，
我觉得，
这也是给我的，
一种情绪价值，
所以,
包括给我发邮件的，
或者是，
真的,
这个其实陪伴我在，
连仓,
非常孤独的两年，
是很重要的一个原因，
就很多朋友问我说，
你到日本那两年，
我住在那个小城市，
就走路五分钟到海边，
但是没有，
不认识任何人，
我，我家人当时，
也还在国内，
你是怎么过来，
你不孤独吗？
我说我演的不孤独，
因为每天，
都在网上有很多的链接，
所以,
这是我去做，
频繁的互动的，
一个很重要的原因，
然后另外一个就是，
我能够观察到，
很多年轻人，
他们在想什么，
其实我很羡慕，
像,
我经常听的一个，
他不是主播，
但是他是嘉宾，
就叫袁昌耕，
他是可能，
在座有些朋友听过，
对，他是人类学的，
一个老师，
云南大学的老师，
他,
因为在课堂上，
就可以看到很多学生，
所以他对于年轻人的，
一些,
想法的把握，
是非常，
得到共鸣的，
那我没有这样的一个，
机会去，
近距离地，
接触到这些，
年轻人，
但是我觉得，
我可以在，
他们,
这是也是我的一个，
荣幸,
甚至是我的一个荣幸，
你老说，
年轻人，
我就觉得，
开始有灯味了，
我跟你讲，
我的感受吧，
就是,
我经常，
从评论区，
我能看到什么，
就是,
比如,
我做那期节目，
第一,
不能说，
然后,
各种评论上来之后呢，
我突然发现了，
一个什么样的中国，
我来跟你讲，
一个大的，
我的感受，
就是以前，
我老觉得，
当我相信这个事的时候，
我的想法，
它不就是这样嘛，
对吧,
但是,
当你看了那些，
海量的评论之后，
你会发现，
人和人之间，
要达成共识，
真的,
不可能的事情，
这么简单一个事，
先差万别的想法，
和观点，
和情绪，
你简直觉得，
天呐,
这,
这个世界太复杂，
所以,
你就决定，
退回同文城是吗？
退回同文城，
然后,
我发现，
同文城在哪儿呢？
现在也是挺凌乱的，
因为这是一个，
就是,
你经常在你伯克里，
要用的那个词，
乱计员，
来,
你给大家描述一下，
就是,
你说的乱计员，
到底是个什么呢？
我觉得，
直到今年，
可能这个词都不用我描述，
大家都，
都能感觉到，
什么叫乱计员，
因为这个词，
出自三体嘛，
对对对，
科幻小说，
然后它描述的是，
在乱计员里面，
就是,
你永远不知道，
第二天会发生什么，
太阳升不升起来，
温度是30度，
还是零下30度，
这些,
其实是小说里的，
游戏里的那个人，
那些人，
就必须要把自己，
变成一张纸，
就是要在，
乱计员里面，
储存下来，
然后到了，
横计员，
到了更加稳定的时代，
你再把自己冲水，
然后,
重新变成一个人，
其实,
我跟,
最早是，
我跟萧萧跑，
是跟我一个好朋友，
我们两在，
那期,
第一期串台的时候，
聊到这个概念，
就是你会觉得，
我们当时的，
主要,
指的是宏观，
还没有重新上台，
也没有想到，
宏观现在，
可以乱成这个样子，
但是,
直到现在，
你就更能体现出，
宏观乱计员下，
每天的地缘政治也好，
然后,
这种经济的事件也好，
是你没有办法预测的，
其实它表现的，
就是一个，
不可预测性，
不可预测性之后，
你会发现，
现在的资本市场，
就很有趣，
因为宏观变得，
越来越不可预测了，
所以大家就，
干脆不看那个东西了，
就越来越，
抛弃,
把握,
以前大家还经常关注，
什么美联储，
到底要不要生息降息，
然后,
美国政府到底在讲什么，
现在都不看了，
我就看一个，
主的去世，
然后我去看一个，
主的技术线，
那你,
AI这个东西，
你怎么不会骗我吧，
你不可能，
明天突然比今天更差了，
你肯定是在往前发展的，
那我就只关注，
于这个点了，
所以,
至少在资本市场，
其实对乱计员，
这个事情拖命了，
但对于我们，
每个人的生活，
其实我觉得，
今天这个题目，
整个什么，
大变局下的普通人，
如何辞储，
我能够connect，
只有普通人三个字，
乱计员对每个人的，
生活的影响，
是只有到，
他真影响到你的时候，
你才突然感觉到，
他影响你了，
这话有点绕啊，
他已经在影响了，
不是,
你可能会觉得，
可能在美国的朋友，
会,
这个体会会更深一点，
因为你有身份，
有签证，
有各种这种东西，
其实在不断的被影响，
其实国内的朋友，
真的是在，
疫情是一个很大的，
转折点，
我身边的很多朋友，
都是在有一个，
具体的事情的时候，
他突然意识到，
原来这个东西，
对我的人生，
对我自己，
会有影响，
包括我自己，
也是那个时间点上，
有了一个，
清晰的体感，
所以乱计员，
可怕就可怕在，
他没有影响你之前，
你都会觉得，
他跟你，
没有关系，
他只是一个，
新闻报道，
发生在远方的事情，
就像在那本小说里面，
很多人，
他也不信邪，
他觉得，
这有什么，
但是等到那个事情，
真的突然发生在那个，
零下30度的温度，
照在你身上的时候，
你就不得不去应对他，
然后如果你到那个时候，
才应对，
可能已经晚了，
就是你已经被冻死了，
那你必须得在这个之前，
意识到这件事情，
已经存在在这个，
物理世界里面了，
然后你如何去应对他，
那现在很多人，
就是你给自己一个荣誉，
你给自己多点选择权，
你给自己多一些可能性，
所以你自己的应对方式，
是什么呢？
既然你已经确认，
这确实是个乱计员，
那你又是个普通人，
方法就是，
资产配置上，
你从钱的这个角度，
就是多元一些，
就是尽可能的，
不去压住在某一个地方，
某一种资产类别，
那对于个体肉身来说，
那就是给自己多一点，
可能性嘛，
为什么我要在日本生活一段时间，
就是因为我需要确认，
就我不知道在疫情期间，
大家有没有在，
中国生活过的那个，
那个经历啊，
就是,
因为我是完整在上海，
待了三个多月的，
就是你不知道哪一天，
哪一刻，
你就突然，
就完全没有办法，
挪动了，
就这种感觉是，
可能在我们这一代，
是从来没有体会过的，
所以从某种程度上来说，
你是不是，
也是个非常悲观的人呢？
哦,
大家看我这个波克的名字，
就知道，
只可能是个悲观的人，
才能起的名字呀，
呵呵呵，
因为你不敢说出下一句，
不是不敢说，
是我觉得，
懂得都懂嘛，
就是你说出来，
其实反而没有意思，
那，问题就来了，
就是说，
如果我们说，
这是一个，
乱计员的话，
其实,
换另一个角度来说，
也经常会带来一些，
出奇不易的，
好的,
或者是机会性，
机遇性的东西，
比如说AI，
就算是一挂，
但我知道你完全错过了，
呵呵,
第一是，
不要这么说，
我觉得，
作为一个内容创作者，
AI，绝对是，
如虎天意的一个东西，
不过没事，
在投资上，
确实是错的，
对，包括美股也是，
这个我们深度交流过，
昨天我还想问你，
认不认输啊，
结果,
太混乱了，
聊了最后都不知道，
那我就想知道，
比如说，
像你也经历过，
就我们这辈儿吧，
其实是经历过，
是一辈儿吗，
哈哈,
绝对是一辈儿，
我比你年轻点吧，
好的,
太无耻了，
其实,
像我们刚才也聊过，
其实像我们也经历过一些，
叫做什么，
时代带来的红利，
比如说房地产，
算是,
我们这辈儿，
至少你买过房，
今天没有什么理财知识，
但是你的财富数量机，
就是会跳跃一次，
那比如说，
像网上导父母那一辈儿，
如果说，
改革开放，
他抓住那个红利，
比如说他去了深圳，
哪怕干个啥，
也是一个，
千载难逢的机会，
再比如说更大的，
比如说全球化，
其实也是一个，
时代的红利，
那我想问的就是说，
其实有的时候，
当你在这个红利里的时候，
你是挺盲目的，
你是没有，
有意思说，
我在这个红利里的，
那,
作为一个普通人，
他这个认知，
和对这个大格局的，
判断,
肯定是，
比不上像Pingo，
这些人，
对吧,
大平洋资管，
那,
普通人怎么能够，
不错过这样的，
机遇呢？
就,
我觉得，
你刚才说的，
前后,
其实就有一些，
矛盾,
如果我们在一个，
红利里面不自知，
其实也就不存在，
什么,
抓住,
或者不抓住，
你只能是，
赶上了就是赶上了，
没有赶上，
你可能，
创运气了，
但是,
反过来，
先讲前面一个，
就是,
我一直认为，
每一轮，
现在的很多，
像红利，
然后什么60后，
一定是，
抓住了，
什么职业的，
发展的红利，
但其实不是这样的，
就是,
哪怕在那一代人里面，
比如你刚讲的深圳，
我们家，
就是在，
80年代末到了深圳，
我们家，
没有因为这个，
改变了命运，
就是,
虽然,
我还有很多朋友，
没买房，
对啊,
一样的，
就是,
其实你，
到回到，
我们刚买房，
2005年,
2009年,
过山车，
做了一波，是吧，
所以,
所以我的意思就是说，
现在的很多，
特别到年轻一代，
他会觉得，
你们这些，
老登们，
都享受了这个红利，
那个红利，
我们没有这个红利，
但首先，
每一代人，
其实享受红利的，
依然是，
你不能说少数，
至少不是全部人，
那所以到现在，
如果你认为，
我认为，
首先,
AI,
不是一个红利，
就好像你不认为，
互联网这件事情，
或者是智能手机，
它是一个红利，
就是,
它是一个东西，
但我相信，
百分之就是，
我们今天这个题目，
普通人，
其实你是没有办法，
从,
创业的这个角度，
抓住它的，
它只会成为，
你的一个工具，
我相信AI到最终，
它也,
这个东西，
本身,
它只会成为你的，
一个工具，
那,
所谓的红利，
到底,
是什么？
它一定是，
某一个，
我认为啊，
当然,
这是可能是，
金融从业人员，
或者钱金融从业人员，
的一些bias，
如果导回到，
我们父母那一辈，
他们的资产，
的这个红利，
其实是，
房地产的前期，
对吧,
他们有一些，
赶上了房地产的，
前期的那个红利，
但他们更多的是，
这个,
所谓工作上，
因为人力资本，
也是一种资本嘛，
我一直这么强调，
他们能抓住的是，
所谓人力资本的红利，
就只要我上学，
然后我能够，
有一个好的工作，
对吧,
我就能够，
把整个家庭的命运，
改变了，
然后到我们这一代，
红利,
就是在资产类别上的红利，
变成了房地产为主，
然后你可能，
还是有一些人力资本的红利，
那到下面这一代，
我认为，
对爱人的事情，
我也是很悲观，
特别是对于安全Level，
就在我作为，
做完最近的这个选题之后，
我就更悲观了，
就是,
现在在很多行业的安全Level，
因为安全Level的工作，
往往都是，
信息收集整理，
然后汇总的这个工作，
而这个工作，
又是最容易被取代的，
但问题是，
没有安全Level，
哪来的，
就这个中间，
你就没有办法变成一个自身的人，
所以我觉得人力，
红利,
可能,
不是接下来，
这个时代，
最核心的这个，
这个红利了，
那房地产也结束了，
那会是什么？
那会是什么呢？
就我现在能想到，
你一定要让我，
做一个，
所谓的预测，
或者什么，
我认为在国内，
依然是，
股权这个东西，
会是一个，
很可能的红利，
我不是股积力，
大家现在就去买A股，
不构成投资建议，
对,
这个时候要加一个，
但是你从，
你从一个大的逻辑上来讲，
居民财富到了这个阶段，
它就是，
会有这么一种变化，
从,
不动产，
到,
股权类的这个，
这个资产，
它就是有这样一个迁移，
以及中国的，
这个存款利率，
它的无风险率，
就是太低了，
以及你没有办法想象，
在未来几年，
它能变高，
就是1%的存款利率，
你很难想象，
它可以，
重新跳到三四，
那么,
现在,
原来大家，
在这个情况下，
会有大量的钱，
它一定要找一个，
找一个去处，
那股权，
我说的股权，
是一个贩股权的概念，
它不一定是，
A股的股票，
或者是港股的股票，
它有可能是，
我一直经常会，
提到的REITs，
房地产，
这个信托基金，
它有可能是保险，
它有可能是债券，
等等的，
这些其实，
我都把它，
我把它，
这些其实，
我都把它，
翻成为一个，
风险资产的类别，
里面,
它会大量的存在在这里的，
那我觉得，
这个就可以，
硬设到，
你其实可以硬设到，
美国,
从五六十年代，
开始的一轮，
巨大的牛市，
那那一代的人，
以及到现在的人，
是怎么抓住这轮牛市的，
绝大部分的普通人，
是不能通过，
朝股这件事情，
抓住它的，
绝大部分的美国普通人，
是通过401K账户，
通过一个非常，
精巧的，
机制设计，
然后,
等它退休的时候，
只要它没有瞎动，
那它可能，
就拥有了一个，
不错的退休账户，
很可惜，
或者说，
很遗憾的是，
到现在为止，
中国还没有，
产生出这样的一个，
设计,
那我,
为什么这本书也好，
或者说是，
经常在节目里，
说的也好，
就是,
那你自己给自己，
对,
设计出一个，
账户来，
它能够，
维持30年，
然后你能把东西，
放在里面，
然后不去动它，
然后把东西，
那你想要抓住的是什么呢？
你想抓住的是，
中国在从发展中，
变成发达国家中，
可能会出现的，
这样的一个，
股权资产上的红利，
我觉得你，
一下把你这个书的重要性，
提的更高了，
借着我的问题，
这是一个时代的红利啊，
你要怎么抓住，
敲门在这儿，
那,
时间也快了，
我就最后再问两个问题，
都是从这书里来的，
认真读了两遍，
希望我也能抓住，
时代红利，
但是这里面你提到了，
比如说，
在做资产配置的时候，
有一个，
或者是在投资的时候，
经常面对的一个问题，
就是,
你要抵抗自己的本性，
对吧,
比如说，
你这里面提过，
人天然的不喜欢损失，
人天然的喜欢，
落带为安的感觉，
人天然的会陷入到，
敘事谬误里面当中去，
那好了，
这些都是我们的本性，
对吧,
看到赔了，
我们就慌，
我想问问，
你自己是怎么祥服，
乳心的，
是,
祥服你的本性？
没,
没祥服得了，
祥服得了，
这不是，
资产又加零了吗？
我们就能跟上这一轮，
AI的浪潮了吗？
但是,
我觉得，
就是,
投资是反人性的事情，
这个是，
一定板上钉钉的，
以及,
我一直觉得，
现在的科技，
金融科技，
把投资这件事情，
变得太容易了，
就显现得太容易了，
就好像每个人，
都能做好投资，
点点鼠标，
或者点点手机上的按键，
买股票，
就能买期权，
你能,
买很多不同，
类型的金融产品，
在二三十年前，
还不是这么，
容易的一个事情，
对不对？
我最近在分一本，
哈佛大学，
两个教授的书，
他当然在讲的是，
美国的个人金融体系，
存在的这个问题，
其实他们就，
他们反映的一个问题，
就在于，
美国的金融机构，
其实一直没有把，
这个事情做得很容易，
不像中国，
有很多的互联企业，
进军到了金融领域之后，
做了支付宝的，
非常做的APP，
它就是比，
什么Fidelity好用，对吧？
但是,
容易不一定是一件好事，
首先,
容易,
肯定不是一件好，
甚至对于投资这件事情，
增加摩擦力，
是投资很重要，
就是,
你如何，
设计投资纪律，
让你在买卖的时候，
要多想一会儿，
多想几天，
是非常重要的一个事情，
那,
对于我来说，
怎么样控制，
你刚才说的，
这些人性上的事情呢，
我觉得，
最好的一个建议，
就是你，
多经历几个周期，
多交学费，是吧？
你看得多一点，
你自然而然，
就说,
这幕我见过，对吧？
这个场合，
我好像，
依稀这个，
赔过钱，
有过印象，
或者是，
你自己如果，
没有见过，
你可能在书里见过，
就这个，
我们刚才在聊那本书，
就是,
我最近看那个，
Solking的1929,。
我的印象就特别的深刻，
那本书，
我非常推荐大家去，
有时间之后翻一翻，
就是,
他写过那个，
too big to fail,。
写过,
当然不能倒，
出色了，
我觉得，
他是一个非常出色的，
金融使人物专辑，
作家,
就他把金融，
落到了每一个个人身上，
然后你去看他写的，
1929里面的一些场景，
我就想起一个场景，
回到我们最早在聊的那个话题，
就是,
你问我纽约是什么样子的，
我现在脑子里有一个场景是什么，
就是我前两天，
在时代广场，
我去找我一个朋友吃饭，
他是Morgan Stanley,。
然后我就在他的大堂等他，
那个大堂背后的那个墙壁，
就是SpaceX上市成功，
宣传海报，
是成功的一个海报，
因为第二天就上市，
就上周四的事情，
然后我转身出来，
时代广场上有一个巨大的，
大家看到没有，
那个马斯克的一个大，
裸露人偶，
裸半身的人偶，
我开始以为他是一个，
庆祝的一个人偶，
但我想的怎么，
画得还挺丑的，对吧，
马斯克怎么想的，
搞这么一个自己的人偶，
然后我知道他的背后，
发现他其实是在，
批判,
就是Groke,。
这个SpaceX底下的AI模型，
会生成ChildPong,。
就是这个儿童色情，
用AI生成儿童色情片，
他是一个，
就是相当于是一个，
抗议的东西，
然后你就会觉得，
他们俩同时出现在，
时代广场的，
就是一个角落，
就是我转角就看到，
这个东西了，
然后在另外一边，
就是在小酒馆里面，
一帮Bankers,。
在兴奋的讨论，
OpenEye,。
跟Anthroopic的上市计划，
因为SpaceX,。
已经可以给我们，
带来一笔，
不菲的bonus了，
我觉得这个就是，
纽约的一个缩影，
就是你不是只有SpaceX，
上市这个，
支持他的一面，
你也有，
去看他那些，
不好的那一面，
然后他是一个，
非常复杂的，
一个体系，
那对于，
我们普通人，
就是你怎么去，
回到刚刚的问题，
你怎么去对抗，
自己的这种，
人性的弱点，
就是你多去看到，
类似这样的一些场景，
你走在，
世界的很多地方，
然后,
对于,
我在美国待过的人，
我可能对SpaceX，
就有了一个，
更加具体的了解，
他就不是现在，
小红书上大家，
可能这两天，
会刷到很多说，
我怎么在190块钱，
你可以涨到1000块钱，
类似这样的一些帖子，
但是你，
实实在在看过之后，
你可能就会有一些，
不同的感觉，
所以就是多经历，
然后多从书上，
或者是多从，
这个,
现实中经历，
是能够帮助你，
抵于,
人性的一种，
很好的方式。
好的，最后一个问题，
就这本书的最后，
其实你，
就是叫做，
拉价值拉得更高，
你说其实投资，
就投世界观的投票，
那我要问问，
你自己的世界观，
是什么呢？
这句话，
其实我也很，
就是我当时回国，
做一系列的活动，
就是签收活动的时候，
有60%以上的朋友，
都希望我把这句话，
写在,
这个书上，
就我没有想到，
有这么多朋友，
经剧突然出来了，
对，喜欢这句话，
因为这句话，
也不是我的原创，
其实是我的一个，
朋友,
一个做基金经理的朋友，
我们在聊天的时候，
他在那里感慨，
因为他觉得，
就之前他抓不住，
因为他不符合他的价值观，
他就在那里，
哀叹这件事情，
说了这句话，
那对于我自己来说，
我相信的世界观，
其实用一句话来形容，
就是万物皆有周期，
就为什么我这么喜欢，
化了马克思，
就是因为我跟他的世界观，
就高攀了，
但是是非常高度一致的，
就是万物皆有周期之下，
你做的所有的决定，
比如说你的分散，
多元化，
或者是你不相信一个，
事情能够，
线性外推，
一直往下走下去，
等等的这些，
其实都是建立在，
万物皆有周期，
这么一个世界观之下的，
但是,
他让你有一个另外的体会，
就是你希望你能够活在当下，
就是因为，
因为既然万物皆有周期，
很多时候你会陷入到虚无主义，
就是他反正会有上有下，
然后那你还干什么呢，对不对？
那怎么对抗这种虚无主义，
就是你在现在当下的生活里面，
发现一些，
比如说我刚刚说我做内容，
想要获得情绪价值，
这就是我给自己找的一个，
非常重要的生活的毛点，
然后他就能让我在我，
有的这种偏悲观的世界观之下，
依然能够，
得过且过，
依然活得还算比较开心吧，
我终于明白，
为什么叫起租楼宴宾客了，
这都是一脉相承的，
这都是周期嘛，
好的，谢谢大家，
来，提问，
提问举手就是了，
然后,
越见到也好，来，
你好,
我在纽约工作，
我就想请问你一下，
就是你自己是怎么对待。
你的资产配置中，
就是汇率变化的风险呢，
我想请你从你这个，
机构工作的经验角度，
聊聊你们是怎么处理，
就是汇率，
波动率的问题，
你后面这半段还挺好的，
就是直接回答了这个问题，
因为,
原来我在主权基金工作的时候，
其实汇率风险，
是这个机构，
研究了很久，
就是到底要怎么去，
因为我们要投资，
大几十种，
B种对吧，
汇率是世界上最难判断的，
价格指标，
没有之一，
因为它是一个双向，
它是比如说，
人民币汇率，
指的是人民币对美元的汇率，
它是两个东西的结合，
一个已经够难判断了，
两个根本判断不出来，
那我们怎么做这个事情呢，
其实就是，
你的,
选择一个本币，
就是比如说，
你在美国生活对吧，
那么美元肯定是你的本币，
那么你的所有的，
比如说你要投资人民币资产，
你的第一考虑是，
我以后，
比如说我的父母，
可能在中国养老，
他们是需要人民币的，
或者说我未来，
可能会回中国养老，
你是有需求的这个基础上，
你去配置外币资产，
这是第一个前提，
就如果你没有在这里，
你没有在那个地方，
生活的需求的话，
尽可能不要去配，
不要去对某种货币有，
执念，或者有判断，
比如说英镑一定会涨，
或者日元一定会涨，
日元一定会涨，
这件事情已经坑死我了，
对吧,
但是因为我在日本生活，
所以你日元再跌对我来说，
虽然可能我在账面上，
是有损失的，
但是我考虑到，
未来五年十年我要花的钱，
这个损失，
对，又不存在了，
所以最怕的就是，
你把汇率这件事情，
当作是你投资指标之一，
其实我们后来主要基金做出来的决定，
其实决定也很简单，
就是不考虑汇率，
就是汇率这个东西，
不纳入每个月，
我们做技校考核，
做所谓的归因的，
重点的这个点里面，
因为它是不可判断的，
但是到了年底，
或者到了一个时间点上，
我们会去去结算，
然后我们也会有相应的研究组，
去给一些明年的，
这种货币的展望，
但是从我工作这么多年的，
经验来看，
几乎所有的对汇率的预测，
是错得最离谱的，
没有人预测得到，
人民币在去年，
这个Liberday解放日的时候，
当它跌到7.3的时候，
没有人能预测到，
一年后的现在它在6.8，
就这件事情是没有人能预测到准的，
所以就不要把这个作为你的预测之一，
当对于机构来说，
你可以用一些衍生品去做hatch，
你可以做把汇率这个事情，
完全拿出去，
但这个是有成本的，
而这个成本，
我觉得对于普通人来说，
是没有必要去承担的，
它可能要占到你几个点的收益，
就没有必要，
所以投资海外市场，
这个其实主要是针对中国人，
他投资海外，
当时很多人来买美元的存款，
他觉得4%一年很香，
结果一年算下来是复收益，
因为人民币升值了不止4%，对吧，
所以这是给大家的一个学费吧，
但如果你未来可能在美国生活，
其实就无所谓啊，
你就算人民币升了4%，
但是anyway我未来是要用的美元，
就没有关系了，
而且我觉得，
我觉得你有点这个妥鸟，
就是汇率太复杂，
我就不考虑，
然后乱纪人太复杂，
是的,
因为对于普通人来说，
你考虑太多，
没有意义，
你考虑不清楚，
来,
你好，谢谢，
你本人有经过很多不一样的工作，
身份的转片，
体质领导体之外，
今天我们讲变局，
我们也讲了乱纪和赛口周期，
那么讲了很多变环，
我想问你，
在你觉得这些转变当中，
你认为最不变的，
或者是最主线的，
最重要的，
不会变的这个底层的能力，
或者是框架是什么，
谢谢,
我觉得，
其实这也不是我，
我觉得我自己很难总结出来，
但是有朋友帮我，
总结出来了，
就是,
我好像总是能，
比较有条理的，
就是,
我是一个比较逼自己的人，
就是在，
哪怕我现在自己只做自媒体了，
你不是经常说我，
对吧，很卷，
就是有，
对,
要更新很多的节目，
就是你永远保持，
对于一件事情的热情之后，
你会逼着自己做很多，
围绕着这个事情的，
相关的事儿，
你比如说，
其实我在金融机构工作的时候，
我曾经有过非常严苛的老板，
但我从来没有觉得，
在他手下干活是很痛苦的，
因为,
他非常的成功，
然后,
他给我的很多东西，
是让我在那两年成长，
非常快的东西，
所以你，
就是总是能，
你可以说我为POA的有点，
有点厉害啊，
或者你比他还卷，
其实,
没有没有，
我没有他卷，
他最近又想找我回去，
然后他给我的，
是哪天，
他的凌晨1点，
我的下午1点，
我们可以打个电话来聊一下嘛，
就是,
这个是非常可怕的一个，
呃，女企业家，
但是我，
我的意思是说，
你如果能够找到一件，
我是在不同的时间点上，
都能找到一个，
我最感兴趣的事儿，
然后围绕的这个事儿，
能够尽可能的去，
安排我的时间，
安排我的经历，
我觉得，
其他的东西，
都有时间来决定，
所以,
我曾经分享过一点点，
就是我是如何，
在这些机构之间，
扭转的，
你会发现，
每一份工作，
可能我怎么从计算机，
跳到金融，
是因为我，
就是对金融，
突然感兴趣，
然后去考了CFA3级，
然后,
哎，我后来的，
主权基金的，
比试题，
居然就是CFA1级的题，
它就是这么巧，
然后那，那，
当然比那些，
可能在金融行业，
已经干了五六年，
十年的人，
对吧,
那后来，
我为什么去了这个，
很卷的女企业家的，
这个机构，
是因为，
他看了我一篇，
公众号的文章，
就这么简单，
那我能来这里，
对吧,
也是一些朋友，
看到,
听了我的播客，
所以,
就是你，
你把你自己，
这个手头的这个事，
干到尽可能的好，
可能,
时间就会告诉你，
它有什么用？
其实,
我觉得，
以我对它的了解，
它最大的特点，
就是,
超级的自律，
我做艺人公司，
我肯定完蛋了，
我就天天，
就乱套了，
我的生物中，
它就是，
极其自律，
你刚才做自媒体，
先生是周庚，对吧？
嗯,
然后,
三档节目，
加强一个不止周庚，
它有三档节目，
封掉了，就是，
而且都是我自己，
剪辑，关键是，
你这要换，
然后那个，
你想,
他做那个，
布希登是，
到了美国之后，
才开始，
做的第三个播客了，
然后,
我一开始以为说，
一个人做一个播客，
你已经有两个了，
而且,
完全不搭计，
这几个，
全生活，
是讲生活了，
这个是讲投资的，
然后还有一个，
突然那天，
又说,
做个light song,。
我天哪，
还在耿，
还在耿吧，
当然在耿，
就是,
你想,
它是个什么，
然后它开，
咖啡室，
然后我们开会，
开了好多次了，
它自己，
还给自己加活，
它是录铁的，
你知道吗？
就是,
你知道，
你去算命，
多多少年了，
一年第十年吧，
第十年，
所以这种人，
真的就是，
而它是少年般的，
它是属于这种，
少年般的人，
永远比你优秀，
还比你情愤，
气死你，
来,
最后一个问题，
就是,
你们刚聊到，
就是说，
住在互联网的，
原住民的那一代，
然后我可能，
我感觉我每天，
就是在美国上学的时候，
每天会听，
大老师播客上下学，
然后会有点，
苦恼,
就说,
我们这代人，
会花很多时间打造，
会很焦虑说，
我没有足够流出，
足够时间深度学习，
我能唯一的深度学习，
时间就听的播客，
要笑笑我，
跑老师的播客，
我潜度学习，
别人的深度学习，
就我知道，
我肯定就是说，
世界观上，
可能就是会有不一样，
所以我就会想，
听您,
比如说，
一天具体操作上，
会怎么，
比如说，
block out,。
这些三小时的，
专注时间呢，
然后可能就是，
不看任何社交媒体，
会想听到这种，
具体操作上建议，
以及智商上，
匹配不上您了，
没有没有没有，
首先我觉得，
你有这样的觉知，
已经可能赢过，
99%的同龄人了，
其次,
我很不好意思地告诉你，
我是一个，
特别,
手机狂，
就是我没有办法，
停止去看信息，
可能每三分钟，
五分钟，
我觉得得看一次，
甚至我在准备，
我只有在录制播客的时候，
比如说，
现在这个场域，
我没有办法看手机，
但哪怕我在准备，
我的稿子，
或者我在写文章的时候，
我都会忍不住看，
有一段时间，
我也曾经，
我最近烦恼过，
我说,
这是不是太消耗经历了，
以及,
你根本就没有办法，
专注于干一件事情，
但后来，
我觉得，
这个事情，
就是我们这一代人，
必须得，
面对的一个事儿，
我随段时间，
看一本，
美国的，
这个记者写的书，
他就是在讲算法，
因为最近我在做这个内容，
他就是叫，
压平文化吧，
他说,
他自己给自己，
设了两周的，
就是所谓的blackout，
就是我完全，
不去刷任何的信息流，
他不说不用手机啊，
不用任何的，
带算法的，
信息流的媒体，
结果是那两周，
他确实感觉，
很舒服，
但两周后，
他发现，
他错过了，
非常多的，
一些,
新闻,
然后他，
感觉就跟不上这个时代了，
因为我们这个时代，
发生的事情，
都是在这些，
信息流里面在，
说的,
所以如果你真的，
把自己，
一定从这些地方，
摘出来，
那你要做好一个准备，
就是,
你可能在，
信息这块，
也会跟这个社会，
有一个脱节，
时间越多，
你可能在那边，
又有确实，
所以,
我倒觉得，
不用有太强的，
这方面的一个，
焦虑,
我有很多的听，
我告诉我说，
他们听播客，
主要是为了补偿，
他们刷短视频的，
三个小时，
就是,
刷三小时，
来听一个小时的播客，
我觉得有这种想法的人，
首先就已经非常好，
就是,
你居然有这样的想法，
你要想，
这个时代，
可能有99%，
有99.9%的人，
是没有这样的想法的，
他们就是在无意识的，
一直在刷，
现在在做的这个事情，
然后,
你相信，
我跟欧阳老师，
是因为到了这个，
灯味非常足的发言，
到了这个年龄，
你积累，
到了这样的一些想法，
其实我在二十多岁的时候，
也完全没有想过，
类似这样的事情，
我用你举个例子，
告诉你一个方法，
就是,
没准你找出一个项目，
通过这个项目来，
深度学习，
会很好，
不跟你举，
就举他的例子，
以我对他的了解，
他不是做那个，
自媒体嘛，
然后他不是到，
纽约来，
在各大新闻学院嘛，
你知道他，
有一天，
他竟然拿着手机，
看麦卡鲁汉，
麦卡鲁汉，
我都惊讶了，
是新闻传播，
加拿大的一个，
特别有名的学者，
然后他的书，
非常不好看，
因为我是学新闻专业的，
我们那时候，
读书的时候，
那是必读书，
我都不读的，
然后他那天，
跟我说，
他在读麦卡鲁汉，
是在微信读书上面读，
拿这个电子设备，
我说,
我脑袋里，
我都不会去读的，
因为特别无聊，
那个麦卡鲁汉，
但是我后来，
理解他为什么做，
因为他有兴趣，
他想了解传播，
就说,
你自己感兴趣题，
你要么，
把它变成一个播客，
或者你想把，
哪怕是，
明儿我吃饭，
我要瞎白话两句，
现在我很懂，
也行,
就这样，
你就会逼迫自己，
去读麦卡鲁汉，
所以这个方法，
我看着他，
我就觉得，
我一开始，
非常不理解，
为什么有这么变态的人，
我看结果，
后来我知道，
天秤他，
你也要做节目，
或者是，
要在各大交流，
对对对，
就如果这个，
总结成一个经验的话，
就是用输出，
倒逼输入嘛，
就是你用不同的方式，
不一定是做播客，
你可能是，
只是给自己写一个东西，
或者是怎么样，
然后你倒逼着自己去做，
输入,
这样的效率是最高的，
对，特别好，
那时间，
时间也到了，
我相信你们，
接下来，
可以多关注他的播客，
好，谢谢大家，
谢谢大家，
可以用你们的，
没事没事，
到微信读书上，
留个好评就行，
对对对，